I need to
sit and watch this
and take it in
and try to figure out exactly
what is going on here.
A video of a racist incidents
circulating online sparking prot
and at least two suspensions
At a Philadelphia high school.
The video there is there it is.
Part of it shows a girl
spraying black paint
on another girl's face
while making comments
referencing Black History Month.
So what's going on?
Jean Casarez joins us.
She's been looking at this video
and she has a report on it
to what happened here.
Let's just state the facts.
Here are the facts.
According to the Archdiocese
of Philadelphia,
three girls are in this video to
Saint Hubert
Catholic High School for Girls
A third girl,
she does not attend the school.
Now, in the video,
a girl is seen spray
painting the face of another gir
throwing around racist insults.
All while several girls are watc
They sit by. They laugh.
Let's watch a little bit of this
girls like, girl,
I know your room.
It's not like
your mom is never letting anyone
to sleep.
Right
after this was doing my laundry.
Takes us
to
a black parent
whose daughter attends
the Catholic school.
Told CNN
the video was sent directly
to his daughter and niece
along with other black students.
Now, the Archdiocese of Philadel
tells CNN
the exact distribution
is unknown at this point of time
What is known
is that the video was taken
outside of school after school h
and then put on social media,
quote, Those allegedly responsib
are not present in school.
They are being disciplined appro
We take this opportunity
to be abundantly clear
that there is no place for hate,
or bigotry at St Hubert's
or in any Catholic school.
It is not acceptable
under any circumstances or at an
The statement goes on to say
that general threats have now be
against the school community
after the video surfaced on soci
They're being reported
as they come in to the Philadelp
Police Department and law enforc
They have been on the campus
since the video surfaced
Philadelphia's branch of the NAA
expressed in a statement Wednesd
a strong disappointment in the v
and called on the school
to, quote, ensure action takes p
Immediately.
I don't really know what to say.
I know it's beyond words.
I mean,
what's the motivation?
What's the state of mind?
What is.
I mean, this is blatantly,
you know,
we've all been young at one poin
So it's closer to,
you know, at least for me to you
You've been younger.
You're younger than I am.
But when I was in college,
you know, people would do stupid
People would openly say the N-wo
But I thought
by the time
we got to 20, 20 to 20, 23
that things would be different.
These kids should know better.
They are kids, though, right?
And, you know,
I want to cut them slack
and that they're kids,
but their actions are reprehensi
Yeah.
And it's not funny.
No, And it should not.
It shouldn't happen.
But it definitely should not be
They should know better.
The consequences of
this will last forever.
This is going to stick with them
I think it'll be very interestin
to see what happens because, you
what is their state of mind here
What are they thinking?
And it was done off campus.
And we know from a recent U.S.
Supreme Court
decision of a high school girl
that didn't.
I was just going to bring up
the SCOTUS decision that.
That's right.
What she did not
she didn't achieve cheerleader
or something.
And off campus,
she made a video
that was absolutely disparaging
the principal and students and t
And it went all the way up to th
Supreme Court.
And they said it's off campus. Y
Freedom of speech. That's right.
It's a really interesting moment
in the First Amendment battle ov
it was this and consequences.
Responsibility on a legal front.
I hope
Ron DeSantis is watching
and paying attention.
I hope that people who are sayin
that we shouldn't
we should only teach certain
aspects of our history are watch
There's nothing funny
about Black History Month
because that's
what we should be learning.
The importance of Black History
because these kids think it's a
and it's perhaps
because they didn't learn it
before they got to college
and maybe they wouldn't
be exhibiting this sort of behav
if they actually knew the histor
of this country.
Right.
And the true history of this cou
and the importance
of at least paying reverence
and attention to the black peopl
who helped to build this country
rather than making fun spraying
someone and saying, oh, it's
Black History Month,
which goes with the archdiocese,
is saying
suspension, expulsion,
you know, we are taking measures
Is that enough?
No, it's not enough.
Learn all of this.
You learn it when you're younger